for representative mcgee who will lead
us
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you representative mcgee i
appreciate that
good morning everybody i'm
representative michael rose
of epping and as chair of the house
science technology
and energy committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a full committee work session
of bills referred to the science
technology and energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting also by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and press a 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
two seven one three six
zero zero or email
hcs at ledge
dot state dot nh dot
uh in the event that the public is
unable to access
the meeting the meeting will be
staff assisting us with the meeting
today includes jennifer four
our committee researcher please note
that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call for
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
that's required under the right to know
law
mr clark please call the roll
representative thomas are you here
no i just get bounced the hell
[Music]
okay
uh mr chairman we we can't hear what's
can you hear me are we of you yeah
that's much better
okay uh i'll go over the ones who didn't
answer
see if they can hear me harry
representative harrington
here oh okay
i should have added my wife's floating
around here too
i'm here at my home and my wife is in
the house somewhere
representative callie pitts i'm here
with my
computer coach my grandson in greenland
and the dog
i'm here i'm at home no one else here
probably on
arsenal president i'm alone in the room
representative mcgee i'm present and i'm
home
i'm here i'm home alone representative
creature
representative uh
here in a room at home alone
three missing so we've got eight 18
president
uh you missed one uh yes i did
i keep doing that because i have to skip
them at the beginning i
represent the chairman votes chairman
rose is here in the committee room
thank you okay you missed two okay
i i went let's go through the ones i
didn't answer
representative vincent
who would i miss about representative
paschall
yes i am here in my room alone okay
chris here yes yes
regnie too oh
you've been called
okay i guess we're all set
mr chair representative thomas
yes i just have a question on my screen
i'm showing the name of uh brad
greenland could you
i can clarify representative thomas um
brad is my colleague and he's going to
be stepping in about 9
45 so he's just arrived early i've got
um
another meeting that i need to attend
with education at 10.
okay thank you i just needed to know
may i ask a question before we begin
representative
what's your yes is it possible for
our committee to have a briefing from
the governor's office about the
proposals having to do with the
department of energy
i've seen a presentation that they have
given
to uh house finance but other
groups of people i'll see if they would
be willing to come and give that same
presentation to us
i can't give you a date for that but
okay so let's uh talk briefly about the
agenda
excuse me mr chairman excuse me uh
representative harrington you have a
question yeah sorry to interrupt i was
just thinking those those handouts
we got from the governor's people last
week maybe if they could be distributed
to the committee that would be a good uh
step to charts that they gave us because
that 65 pages is pretty confusing
those handouts uh might be helpful for
everybody in the committee
to get you know the ones i'm referring
to
that's a good suggestion representative
harrington i don't have those
slides in an electronic format at the
moment but i can try to get them from
if you'd like i can get them and just
distribute them
mr chairman uh some of the others
like me i haven't seen it so they could
be distributed to the committee as a
whole
as i just indicated to representative
harrington i will do my best to make
that happen
i do not have them in electronic format
at the moment
and that's the way most people receive
information from the committee these
days
if you'd like i could get those for it
and then distribute them mr chairman
okay representative harrington i'll task
you with that
uh i appreciate i appreciate you taking
that on
thank you so we will get you the slides
from
the governor's office about the new
department of energy i don't know how
useful they will be without someone to
to
explain what the slides mean but we'll
get them to you anyway
and we'll try to arrange a presentation
by the governor's office
thank you very much you're welcome so
let's talk
now about the agenda for today i have
made arrangements
to get a couple of folks from
iso new england to come and talk to us
starting at 10 o'clock this morning
about
the transmission system in new england
they're going to explain to us just
exactly how
they administer the transmission
network in new england and they're going
to explain to us
what the impacts are of
energy efficiency renewable energy on
transmission costs
they will be here at 10 o'clock i
believe they're available
until about 11 30 and
they'll give us a presentation and then
they'll take our questions so we'll have
plenty of time
to ask them questions about
transmission costs which is an important
topic that comes up
over and over in our public hearings and
our other discussions so i think it's
worthwhile
to see what uh iso new england has to
say on that topic so we'll do that
at 10 o'clock between now and then we
need to
transact some business as i indicated
in an email that i said to all of you
earlier
we did discover a typo
in the amendment we adopted to house
bill
315 it was a simple
one-word strikethrough of the word
provide
but that's an important part of the
amendment
and we really need to fix that
error so i have asked it osos to draft a
new amendment
which i sent to you all it's 2021-0748
h and um what i would like to do this
morning is open an
executive session on hp315
i will make a motion to reconsider
hp315 if that motion passes i will then
make a motion
to adopt the amendment 2021-0748
h and presumably that will pass
well i haven't opened the executive
session yet
i'll call make sure to call and you've
got representative kelly fitz
so that's uh that's the main piece of
business that i would like to conduct
between now
and 10 o'clock i had originally hoped
that we would be able to have a working
session today
on house bill 106.
unfortunately after we retained that
bill
i did not explicitly
enough apparently say to the clerk and
the committee admin
that i wanted to hold on to that and the
bill got transmitted to the house clerk
as retained and that apparently is an
action that cannot be retracted
or undone i had a lengthy
telephone conversation with the house
clerk and he
explained to me that we can no longer
take any action on house bill 106
until the speaker gives us permission
deal with retained bills so
unfortunately
we're not going to be able to bring
forth any amendments on hb 106 this
morning
we can't even really discuss it because
the speaker hasn't given us
permission to discuss virginia's bills
i will point out however that senate
bill
109 which should arrive
in our committee in another week or two
is very very similar to house bill 106
so we will get a second bite at that
apple
and we can hopefully come up with a
compromise position on senate bill 109.
that we can all live with and that the
senate
will accept so we will plan to have a
lengthy
discussion about that bill of course
we'll have a public hearing on it as
well and
then we'll have a work session and we'll
try to come up with a way to
create a compromise that makes as many
people happy
as possible so that's the plan
uh representative samson you have a
question
yes um thank you mr chair um
well i'm really disappointed that we
can't uh talk about hp
106 today um as you well know you you
assured us that we would have that
opportunity and you would retain this
bill
and i can certainly understand that
mistakes can be made
however it is um an issue that has come
up in the house sessions as well
where i believe the speaker has made
several mistakes where
the remedy seemed to be uh i apologize
for my mistake but i can't revert
or mitigate those mistakes i think these
are
these are acts that tend to uh generate
a lot of mistrust
and i think it's a it's not a good thing
for us we should be generating more
trust among each other
and not mistrust so i'm disappointed
about this and i think it it
doesn't do us very much uh good here
that these things happen and when they
do happen
they must be a media remediation effort
done
and if the only remediation is to say
sorry we made a mistake
you can't do anything about it that's
not that's not very satisfactory
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative samson
i did apologize to the committee in my
email
for the mistake that caused the
miscommunity education that caused this
mistake i'll apologize again
here in person making that mistake
and in my defense i'll point out that
i'm a new committee chair
we have a new committee clerk we have a
new committee vice chair
and it's inevitable that a mistake is
going to happen on occasion
it's also inevitable given the
[Music]
in which we are conducting our business
where i haven't even
spoken in person to our committee admin
since the
[Music]
glitches like this and
i apologize once again for the fact that
it happened
but it did happen so now we just have to
deal with it
representative flett you're yes i would
just say
that the circumstances under which we
are living this year
with the covent situation does not
help communications at all and so uh
i think uh the mistake that was made is
understandable
and uh i i won't want to dwell on it and
i just remember the last two years with
lots of stuff i didn't
just leave it there thank you
representative callie pitts
all i wanted to say was i i had called
the clerk on this
and that is irreversible and that
i think that in this committee we
we are polite to each other but i think
we have to pay
more attention to each other instead of
trying to think ahead and i think that's
normal under these circumstances with
zoom
and i thank god we're all human because
we've all made mistakes and we will
probably
continue to make mistakes but we will be
dealing with 106
in september or before if the speaker
allows
thank you thank you
representative callie fitz so
with that uh said what i would like to
do now is convene
in an executive session on house bill
315.
and having voted on the prevailing side
i move that we reconsider our vote on hb
315. representative callie pitts
second it it's been moved and seconded
that we reconsider
our vote on hb 315
this reconsideration is for the purpose
of
adopting a new amendment that corrects
an error
in the amendment that we adopted
previously
and i would ask you all to vote in the
informative
on this motion is there any further
discussion
[Music]
seeing none i asked the house clerk to
call the roll on the motion to
reconsider house bill 315.
representative thomas
yes preserve harrington yes president
is she present yet no representative
representative progression yes
representative
yes yes
yes
yes representative kelly pitts
yes representative man yes
[Music]
yes representative vincent not president
yet
representative mcgee yes representative
williams
yes representative preacher
representative pimentel
yes representative partial yes
and the chairman chair votes yes
okay and the two abstentions 19 yes
5 3 18 yes
thank you by a vote of 18 to nothing
the motion to reconsider hb 315
passes mr chair uh
okay uh for the record uh representative
plett
uh there are no abstentions in a vote
if you could just you know make sure
that doesn't get recorded that way it's
recorded as 1803 absences
thank you for that clarification
representative thomas
okay i now move the adoption of
amendment 2021-0748
second it's been removed and seconded
that we adopt
amendment 2021-0748-h
there are copies here in the committee
room
for those of you who are here and i sent
a copy of this amendment
to everyone via email i hope everyone
has had a chance to look at it
the only change that this amendment
makes is on page one
line five in the previous amendment
the word provide had a strike through
through it in this amendment the word
provide
does has no strike through that
is the amendment that we intended
to adopt last time around but none of us
noticed
matthew fossum an attorney for
eversource has verified
that this amendment is the correct one
the honorable clifton bureau of the city
of lebanon has also verified that this
amendment is the correct one henry
herndon
of clean energy new hampshire has also
verified that this
amendment is the correct one i have been
through it myself
and i verify that it is the
amendment that we all agreed to in our
stakeholder process to develop this
amendment
for this bill does anyone else have any
comments that they would like to make
did you have a comment i thought i saw
your hand go up
yes i'm sorry i i muted myself when i
thought i unmuted myself
uh first uh henry herndon is no longer
with clean energy new hampshire
he's with the uh i believe it's called
the community power alliance
and secondly i i know for my part i
didn't think it was
a typo or or missed the typo i thought
that was part of the compromise
and i bring this up because when we have
these continual amendments
and we bring in an outside authority
such as cliff below it's all too easy to
assume
that the changes that were made are
are the ones that have been vetted and i
i just i i just i
wanted to reiterate that how careful we
need to be
when we have multi-page amendments
and i believe that one came in the
morning of
the the session where we considered it
did it not
no that's not correct uh that was sent
to you at least
three or four days ahead of time
[Music]
okay just then as a final point as we go
forward it would be really useful if we
always
try to have these out several days
ahead of time so that people do have
time to to really give them the
fine-tooth comb because
trying to read over this to ensure that
provide really was
the only change was a a really uh
difficult task thank you
thank you representative i will say that
the stakeholder process involves a lot
of people
and we had multiple versions of the
in that kind of a situation it's easy
for this kind of mistake to get made
unfortunately
i could have left that mistake
i could have let it ride and ask the
senate to fix it
but that just didn't seem right to me if
we know we have a mistake it's our bill
it seems to me it's up to us to fix the
mistake not try to pass that
task off to somebody else so that's why
i
uh this process this morning to
re-adopt the amendment and adopt the
correctness
is there any other discussion on this
amendment
representative threat i'll just point
out that the circumstances
we're living under cousin colvin also
affects our relationship with ols it's
harder for them to do their job
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
on the amendment 2021-0748-h
mr clark representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative lotter not here
representative
yes representative clint votes yes
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative
yes representative
yes oh okay you are representing samsit
representative kelly pitchford yes
representative yes representative
vincent
representative mcgee yes
yes
[Music]
and how do you vote i'm i voted yes
okay i'm marking it now so uh we have
representatives matter i'm
i have to make sure i have to do this
again sorry
i'll go through it again and make sure i
have it right representative thomas
hello
representative yes representative
bernardi
yes president of cambridge yes
representative closure
yes
yes tom your mic is making a lot of
background noise
by the way representative samsic
yes representative kelly pitts yes
representative man
yes you're arsenal yes
vincent
mcgee yes
uh representative mc williams yes
representative yes we're partial
yes uh and chairman votes
chair votes yes 1803
okay by a vote of 18 to nothing
amendment 2021-0748
h is adopted i now move
pass hb 315 as
representative samson
uh second it's been arrived and seconded
that we
adopt hb 315 otp
a is there any further discussion
yes mr chair representative thomas
uh sorry for being a stickler but since
this is being recorded for the record uh
the motion
should be adopt um uh uh hb
okay thank you for that correction and
for the record that's what i have on the
roster
thank you so we're voting on
on uh the motion to adopt
hb 315 as amended any further discussion
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the role
on the question of the adoption
of hb 315 as amended
representative thomas yes representative
harrington
yes representative daughter not
president
representative murder yes representative
platforms yes representative
[Music]
yes represents
represent a man yes representative boxer
yes of your invention
representative mcgee yes prince edward
williams
representative pimentel yes you're
partial
and the chairman votes yes
okay did you record jay's
response uh is my mind
i vote yes
[Music]
okay by a vote of 18 to nothing
hb 315 is
uh past otp
that's as amended and i thank you all
for your patience and your understanding
in making sure that we do this right
i feel very confident at this point that
we can turn this bill over to the clerk
representative pled is recognized could
uh since it's 18 00
well when we tried that before
representative callie fitz objected
we could ask her again if she objects to
that
representative callie pitts are you
there
she may have stepped out of the room i
would object
okay representative oxendine would
representative oxen did you have your
hand up did you want to speak
uh yes i do it it's on a different
matter i can wait until
your you've completed the action on this
bill sir
okay thank you so i will now close the
executive session
on hb 315 and once again thanks to
everybody
thank you very much earlier you said
that the speaker has to give us
permission to
discuss retained bills before we can do
that
am i correct did i hear you correctly
you did hear me
correctly that is what the clerk told me
in our conversation
telephone conversation yesterday before
because i was wondering about possibly
getting in
some expert speakers that we could begin
to
uh explore some of the issues that will
be coming up on retain bill would that
be possible during this
interim period that we have before us
yes in fact we're doing we're starting
that process today
by having a presentation on transmission
costs by
iso new england and sausage
has and i have been discussing the
possibility of bringing in some folks
who
understand the intricacies of
financing renewable energy projects
to explain to us just exactly how those
projects get
financed and put together i think that
would be useful information for the
committee to have
and as soon as we can pull that together
i will
arrange a work session for us to to have
that
have that discussion it's just slight
difference here that i i was trying to
make sure that i wasn't stepping on any
toes that
these are presentations on general
topics whereas
say the broadband bill if we wanted to
have somebody come in and talk to us
about broadband
if we might be out of order because we
were discussing
something that was in a retained bill
and we had not yet received permission
to do so from the speaker
so it's my understanding that it's okay
to proceed with
inviting such experts and then try to
set up a time
would that be with you or would that be
with the clerk or the vice
chair i would it would go through me
and we can do that as you suggest
thank you so much representative thomas
and i would work together
uh along with representative samsic to
make those events happen
we'll try to put some of those together
i will alert you though to the fact that
very soon now we will start receiving
bills from the senate
and once we receive those bills we'll
need to
start scheduling public hearings for
those
bills so that we can take care of that
business as
expeditiously as possible so that may
delay
if you will any discussions we have with
outside experts about other issues but
we'll work it all in as best we can over
the course of the next
few weeks and we'll get our work done
have a question about it speaking of
that
i would remind you all that the speaker
has scheduled
three house sessions for april 7 8
and nine which are our wednesday
thursday and friday
a friday session is unusual but not
unprecedented according to the speaker
and all three of those sessions will be
held at the
bedford sports complex
same place we met on february 24th
and 25th and the speaker has indicated
that
the session we had there on the 24th and
25th
uncovered some issues
with being able to hear
participants who are spread out over
such such a large area
and so the speaker's office is trying to
take actions to allow
all persons in attendance at the
sessions on
april 7 8 9 to be able to be recognized
and
heard whenever they
want to speak so hopefully we will avoid
some of the
problems that we had on february 24th
and 25th representative mcgee
yes thank you mr chairman i just had a
question uh i had heard recently
normally we have a a budget overview
for the house before we have to vote on
the budget
and i know that there's a sort of a
question floating out there so i was
just wondering if
if you had heard anything in leadership
about whether we will have a review
of what's in the budget before we have
to
vote
haven't heard any specific talk about
that uh i do know from past experience
that
there will be a budget presentation
but i haven't it hasn't been scheduled
yet for my knowledge
and i don't know
when it will be scheduled i don't i'm
not sure if we will be voting on the
budget on april 7
8 or 9. that's not clear to me but
i'll try to get an answer to that
question and get back to you
another thing that that we all need to
keep in mind
with regard to the session coming up on
april 7
8 and 9 is that we need
to be careful with our floor debates
we have an awful lot of bills to deal
with and a lot of ground to cover
on those three days and while apparently
we have that facility
from nine in the morning till six in the
evening
it still may not be enough time if we
get carried away with our floor debates
so i would urge everyone on the
committee to
plan carefully your floor debates
make sure that your floor speeches are
as succinct
as possible make your
one two or three points as quickly as
you can
so that the events of the day can move
along
an expeditious fashion we don't
really i don't think benefit from
long force people
already made up their mind about how
they're going to vote before we get to
the floor
so a lot of people say they pay more
attention to
pis than they do before speeches so i
just
ask everybody to think about that as
they plan their floor speeches
in the upcoming session
now we're going to have isd iso new
england here in about
20 minutes are there any topics that any
of you would like to discuss
seeing none i guess maybe we can uh take
a
a break let's take a 15 minute break
and reassemble at five minutes of
10. each time we will begin the
presentation by
thank you
[Music]
oh
b
[Music]
is my mic a little better now michael
i mean i was having trouble earlier
yeah there's there's like a background
like
hum still there right like yeah it's
still there
okay i'm i'm by myself in a room there's
nothing around it might be something
electronics
i'll check it out again thanks
thanks my suspicion on that might be it
might be coming
from the uh desk in the chambers
uh somebody is not close the mic right
now but when they start
uh perhaps when they move up the
microphone that goes away
so i suspect it's from the chambers but
good luck cutting it down
first first time i did it from home so
and i might be stepping away if i have a
phone call so
good day okay how you doing
louis is it louis lucious
delicious yes hey tell me something are
you
new this year yes i am how are you
finding the experience
the thing i'm liking is i used to be in
research
and getting these bills going through
everything
that's what i like but um
i'm trying to step trying to stay away
from this pretty
partisanship well
i'm kind of feeling the same way i gotta
be honest it is a wake-up call walking
into that hall
and hearing a lot of that i'd like to
think that i would like to think of a
fair-minded i guess
but uh boy there's a lot to learn though
i feel like i mean personally i don't
know if you feel that way it's a
lot of information coming down on this
yes i've been going to a lot of uh
former
reps so i don't bias
myself with the ones voting this year
so i reached out to some of the former
reps and especially my district
and uh i thought i was going to be in
another committee
and it was a fit for me and this one so
i
came here so
[Music]
where are you from again what town i'm
in center harbor representing um
that new hampton belknap one
okay yeah once again my mic is that
still working
is your what uh my microphone i had
background noise
i'm still hurting oh but i don't that's
you or not
okay it's when it's when you don't talk
like
there's like a background hum okay that
kicks in and it overrides the room
mic so we can't hear when he's calling
for some reason
yeah yeah i couldn't hear my bull coming
through
when i was waiting so that was probably
why
there's a setting they can do on a zoom
where you can uh
select how much background noise you
allow yeah i tried all three of them it
didn't seem to change it
okay that's why i asked a few times
but nothing seemed to change it even if
it's still there
now if i'm quite a
maybe need a little cradle for your
microphone
oh i don't need multiple
yeah i'm expecting a phone i was asked
to stay by my phone today for family
business
and uh so that's why i'm here then i see
that
the room it's almost empty so i wasn't
the only one
i think people look into a short day
today i don't know if we're gonna go
past noon
i don't know i
[Music]
that's right i was thinking of uh 106
was going to be discussed too and i
forgot it was uh
caught into being retained yeah that was
it was a disappointment but
yeah my notes i had both of them so i
forgot about that
isn't that funny i was just going to say
note to self if we vote to retain
the bill is going to be retained we
shouldn't have voted
you know we should have left it in
committee if we really wanted to leave
it in committee
but um yeah i hope that we get to ask
more from the iso new england just about
the transmission costs i want to learn
about that but there's a lot more
like grid security and stability and
what you know
what percent of renewables on the system
creates instability like they do
reporting on all kinds of really
interesting topics
that we should be more informed on so i
i hope it's not just limited to
that although our transmission our
percentage of the transmission costs has
gone up
and so i also would like to know what
that 10.5 or 10.8
equates to in dollars because
um we should understand that i think
representative mcgee it's
my experience in dealing with iso new
england that
when they're asked to give a
presentation about a particular subject
that's all they prepare for so hopefully
we can stick to the transmission portion
of there
uh because if we ask other uh
diverse questions that that person may
not have been the one
to to deal in that so we um
but if we want to have more information
i'm sure they would say they can get
someone else to come in and
answer some questions also in the past
before if we've had more questions
um we have been asked to submit them
and that they would get back to us as
well so hopefully that will
that will be the case this time yeah i'm
sure they'll be able to field whatever
question i mean if we get an answer we
don't get an answer but
all right let's uh let's get started
again excuse me
brad greenland are you there
yes i am brad would you elevate
mr johnson or maybe you already did you
haven't
okay mr johnson is there okay
so we can now
and i will ask eric johnson from
iso to take the floor
and uh talk to us about
transmission costs in new england
how they're allocated amongst the states
and how they affect energy efficiency
and renewable energy in our state
so mr johnson welcome to the
new hampshire house science technology
and
energy committee we look forward to uh
hearing from you this morning
and you are free to take it away
good morning thank you much very much
good to see you just want to do a quick
audio check can you hear me clearly we
can thank you
all right sounds good uh i dialed in uh
just a few minutes before i was
introduced
i understand there's a interest in a few
other topics i'll do my best to answer
those today or
follow up as needed to assist the
committee
for the uh record my name is eric
johnson i'm director of
external affairs for iso new england
based in holyoke
and i i miss the opportunity to wake up
at
five in the morning to make the trip to
concord but hopefully
at some point in the future we'll be
back and grab a cup of coffee across the
street
and visit you in person i was asked to
talk about transmission costs how
they're allocated
to the states and when we talk about
transmission just to clarify we're
talking about the
the bulk transmission system which is
the high voltage
wires in the region we're not
talking about the poles and wires in the
local community which make up the
distribution system so i just want to
set that distinction
the transmission costs are not
allocated uh directly to the states so i
just wanted to make that clear
up front we we can show an approximation
of what that is
on a state-by-state basis and i think
that's helpful to see
what that looks like region wide we've
prevented presented a similar
uh set of data in the past but currently
if you think of the allocation of the
cost it's based on something called the
network load in the region
and it's essentially the amount of
electricity that's being
consumed across the new england electric
grid
and our grid is a tightly integrated
system so everything from
maine to connecticut and all the states
are in between
are interconnected and then we have
interconnections
to our neighbors but we're only talking
about the transmission system within
the new england borders and so the
network load for new hampshire for 2019
as an example
was 9.5 percent
now that number is relatively constant
over time we don't see
significant shifts in the regional
network
load in any of the states
i'll give you the numbers for the other
states and i'm happy to provide this in
writing if it's helpful
so i mentioned new hampshire is 9.5
connecticut is 25.5 percent
massachusetts is the largest at 45.8
percent
vermont at 4 percent
rhode island at 6.3 percent
in maine at 8.9
so if you think of those percentages the
largest would be massachusetts
followed by connecticut followed by
new hampshire followed by maine then
rhode island in vermont
transmission relates to the renewables
and if you think about
the renewables that are coming onto the
system in new england we have
large scale grid connected resources
those could be a gas fire generation
which we've seen over the past decade or
more recently we're seeing
wind-based projects onshore and offshore
wind
projects that are grid connected the
large generators
they don't tend to impact
the regional network load because they
come onto the grid as
supply they're putting power onto the
system
but we also see a lot of distributed
resources
across the region and much of that is
solar right now the pv resources
and you can think of the rooftop solar
arrays
most of those are being sponsored by uh
state incentive programs
so a customer would put a solar
installation
on their home or their building
and that does not look like supply to
the iso it looks like
a reduction in electricity demand so we
would
generally say they are behind the meter
resources
so as we are managing the electricity
consumption on the grid
we're starting to see that the the grid
demand
drops on a day when you have
sunshine like today as the
customers who would normally be using
power from the grid are now
sourcing some of their energy directly
directly from those solar resources
and so it looks like a reduction in the
demand
on the grid so the regional network load
coming back to that concept
the large scale grid connected resources
don't have an impact
but the smaller resources would the
behind the meter resources would so they
would
in effect reduce the load on the system
so that's one of the ways it would have
an impact you could also draw
a similar correlation to an energy
efficiency which
like rooftop solar is an installation of
a device or a measure
on the customer side of the meter and
when you roll up all of the energy
efficiency across new england
to the iso it looks like a reduction in
demand on the grid just the way it does
for that
customer who's installed typically a
more efficient
lighting system or could be a chiller at
a
larger facility so those are some of the
initial thoughts on the concept of how
costs are allocated
not directly to the states but we can
roll up the charges
that the states incur and you can think
of a
state like connecticut would have two
customers for transmission primarily
it would be eversource and united
illuminating
and then in new hampshire it would be
psnh
and any of the other utilities operating
in the state and then we roll up
all of the utilities in each state to
give you the figures that i had
mentioned before
so the iso doesn't have a way to bill
states
we allocate these costs uh to the
utilities
they collect the revenue that they need
through a rate that's approved by the
ferc
the federal energy regulatory commission
so
uh that is not set by the iso uh the iso
is really
uh a settle provides a settlement
function
of of collecting those costs and
we would make the payments to the
transmission companies that have made
the investments
in the transmission system so i know
there were some other questions but
i think i could maybe stop there and see
if that
is helpful and if you want to expand or
ask any other related questions
thank you uh representative plett is
recognized for a question
so thank you mr chairman uh eric great
to see you again
for hear from you anyway um
it's been i used to go to isilon
newport meetings um some
states are trying to increase net
metering in an attempt that
transmission costs a transition cost but
an attempt to reduce the percentage
from that from a particular state so
that the
class shift the burden is on other
states
from what you're saying any attempt like
that hasn't really been successful
because it's pretty steady is that
correct
um well first of all representative
plett it's nice to see you
and to address you as representative
having worked with you at the
many of the regional stakeholder
meetings i don't see you on camera so i
assume you might be in the large
building
oh yeah large medium okay very good you
don't see me on camera
if we think about energy efficiency
massachusetts historically has been
ranked first in the country and they've
been back and forth in first place with
california for
investments in energy efficiency and
they're trying to do that to make sure
they're more efficient
and controlling their energy consumption
and giving customers tools to do
that so they would be one of the most
aggressive
in terms of the state policy for
implementing energy efficiency but they
would be doing that
based on their their own objectives
there's no requirements
at the iso level for states to invest
in energy efficiency or take actions
like that that might affect the
transmission
costs so we may observe
that some states spend more than others
on energy efficiency but
we don't have a direct role in that now
it
is possible and this is i'm just kind of
thinking out loud
if if some of the states in the region
invest heavily in transmission in energy
efficiency
and others don't invest in energy
efficiency you could see
a shift in the cost because they would
be in effect reducing
uh the regional network load within
their state
but we've seen a lot of investment in
energy efficiency for
many many years in the region and we
haven't seen these numbers
uh shift dramatically so i think you
have to make your own
determination on whether or not there's
a cost
shift for the investments that are made
in any one technology whether it's
efficiency or
solar pv oh
if there were a concerted effort by a
particular state
to reduce its uh pro rata share of the
transmission by
uh aggressive uh net metering behind
uh uh would iso new england let that
stand or would it
redefine how the uh voters how the
transmission is out here
we wouldn't we do not have a role in
that uh as i mentioned
our our only role in this space is to
provide the settlement function so the
money would be collected
uh by the iso and then it would be paid
to the companies that are
building the transmission and operating
the transmission system
so as i mentioned the rates for the
regional network service are all
subject to uh review and approval by fur
so they're developed by the transmission
owners it goes to ferc
there's information about it that's
posted on the iso website
and we provide the settlement which is
just the
exchange of money it's a transaction
but we don't have any policy in this
area
okay thank you uh mr johnson i have a
question for you
we hear in testimony before this
committee
over and over again that the adoption of
certain
policies regarding energy efficiency or
renewable
energy reduces our transmission
load and therefore our transmission
costs
is there any way to measure
those reduced costs and or that reduced
load
we do publish the monthly
regional network load data and we've
shared that with a committee in the past
and i believe uh
chairman that's a file that you had
shared with us in advance
asking for some uh perspectives on
and it's publicly available
and what you could do is look back in
time
at new hampshire's share of the
network load relative to each of the
other states
so the numbers i gave you are a annual
snapshot
for the region but you can look at that
on a monthly basis
but the trend over over many years is
there's a little bit of
fluctuation month to month but there
could be other things
driving that as well it could be
variations in the weather within the
region that drive
the consumption in southern new england
versus
some of the northern new england states
there there may be other factors so
it's hard to draw out an inference that
energy efficiency explicitly is causing
the changes in the regional network load
over time
you would have to make some assumptions
to unpack that data
the information we're showing is simply
what we see on
we can't look behind the meter to figure
out how much is energy efficiency
versus how much is you know other things
so if i understood you correctly you're
saying
and i have looked at that monthly load
data
you're saying that there are a variety
of causes
to explain the
ups and downs on a monthly basis
of the load some of it could be
renewable energy or energy efficiency
but other
reasons could include the weather and
other variables is that what i heard you
to say
yes okay thank you representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
johnson for coming to speak with us
today
my question is how the iso new england
views the
load reduction from behind the meter
assets in terms of grid reliability
because i know you you put out reports
very often that's your primary charge
as an iso and i just wondered how
how those changes in the management of
the grid
are perceived by the iso because i think
one of the conversations that comes up
in terms of policy making is
what's the threshold for
renewables coming onto the grid at which
you know
it's no longer of the benefit that we
all think it is
and i think that those conversations are
going on all over the country so i'm
just curious if you could speak to
the reliability piece and how you view
um
those assets coming online in terms of
you know we're now able to all talk of
them as load reducers
but how much load reduction
can we sustain and how do you guys view
it in terms of the stability of the grid
uh thank you representative mcgee a good
question right reliability really is job
one for us
uh from the time that we were created as
organization it was to
make sure we operate and plan the system
reliably for the
six new england states when we think
about
renewables we don't think of renewables
any differently than
any other technology that would come
onto the grid
so we we take our independence
uh very seriously we're technology
neutral when it comes to resources
so any any resource that wants to tie
into the bulk power system
we would study the interconnection of
that project
and you may have heard of the uh the
queue
that the iso maintains the generator
interconnection study queue
it's like when you go to the deli and
you want to place your order you pull a
number
and you get your q position and so we do
that for every project that wants to tie
into the grid
historically those have been the large
gas-fired plants but now we're seeing
that for
wind farms and we're starting to see it
for some large
solar arrays in the region so
when a project comes forward we want to
study it to make sure that it will have
no
adverse impact on the reliability of the
rest of the grid
or anybody connected to it so
the test is no adverse impact
and if we do detect that there are
problems
we could require the developer to
upgrade
substations or transmission facilities
in the area to make sure it can connect
reliably we don't want anybody plugging
into the grid
and causing problems for other entities
so
that's been part of our responsibility
since the beginning
it continues to be and we wouldn't let a
asset of any kind
connect to the grid if it would cause
reliability problems
but if you think about the small
distributed resources
the solar pv we don't have any decision
making
in that area at all we simply see
the load reduction and there's no
resource
that's wired into our system
it just shows up as the reduction so
if you think about the typical load
profile
in the region everybody wakes up you
know in the in the early morning hours
and the demand for power builds
throughout the day
and one of the challenges that we see
with operating a system with growing
penetration
of solar pv resources is that you are
increasing the ramp of power that you
need
in the afternoon as the solar goes
offline
so we're able to manage that uh there's
there's always been a ramp between the
the afternoon and the evening but
because the solar pv has brought the
demand on the grid down
so significantly on a sunny day it's
created a steeper
ramp to the evening peak so we need to
make sure we have resources that are
flexible
and fast enough to be able to come on as
the solar
is going offline and if you'll pardon me
for just one minute
i have to go let the dog out i'm sorry
be right back
he he's in charge right now okay
representative thomas will be recognized
next
[Music]
okay representative thomas go ahead and
well is uh mr johnson back ready to hear
my question
no oh yes yes i'm here
all right thank you um yes uh this
uh deviates slightly from the subject
but
you mentioned reliability my question
involves in terms of the pandemic and
people
currently working more at home and in
terms of the fact that in the last
several years
the new england region has done a lot
to increase its reliability through iso
new england there have been a lot of
projects
reliability projects that that have come
on
which of course all all of the states
do you see a ramping down
of those reliably reliability projects
coming soon and how
would you um how would you comment
on how they will be affecting the
overall electric bills of our of the
ordinary citizens
as these projects come down and also in
relationship to whether or not
you may see more people working from
home in terms of
use of electricity uh what the point i'm
getting at is
as we attempt to do some policy making
to
try to reduce the cost of electricity to
our
constituents are we looking at skewed
data
and are we going to overreact or do you
see uh
where do you see that the states may
need to want to go
in terms of reducing people's electric
bills knowing that
all of these past data might be coming
down that we're at the tail end of these
things
if you understand my question correctly
it's kind of convoluted but
there's a lot of moving parts in there
okay maybe you could just clarify
representative thomas the the point
about
reliability projects coming down i just
want to make sure i understood that
reference
mine there have been many projects
throughout new england
to improve reliability a case in point
recently in new hampshire was the
merrimack valley reliability project
and a lot of these projects were done
i'm pretty sure
because of the big ice storm we had many
years ago uh
people needed people were without power
for many many
many days and uh a lot of reliability
efforts were done at the time to make
sure that didn't happen again
my understanding is that the amount of
projects that
were being done uh have gone over the
hump
and we're now on the downswing as far as
finishing up these projects
so perhaps there won't be as many
reliably projects being done
in within the region therefore the cost
of those projects will be coming down
uh is what i was getting at so where do
you see us going in the next
say two to three years in terms of
what we can do for policy making while
not
using the past data as potentially
skewed data because
uh we we've been high in the region but
uh we've been high for many reasons you
know where do you see us
come coming forward are we going to be
overreacting or
or are we or should we be using that
past data
um to to judge where we need to go
okay that's helpful thanks for the
clarification
the the reliability projects that new
england has
invested in over the past decade uh
total about
uh 10 billion dollars round numbers and
that's the cost of building and then
maintaining
the bulk power system and then the costs
of that are allocated
along the lines of the percentages we
talked about earlier
uh we're coming uh really to the end of
the
the build out of most of those
reliability projects
we have about two billion dollars of
projects that are still planned
and part of our system we don't see
significant transmission required for
reliability beyond that
the the exception might be if we see the
retirement of a
large uh generating resource
that provided support to the grid in a
certain area we may have to
restudy the system without that asset
and that could trigger a need for
transmission we did see that in the
boston area when the mystic generating
units
retired so we had to make some
transmission reinforcements
but we are not going to see an
indefinite
growth in reliability based projects
that's our current view we do expect
based on what the states
in the region are looking at for uh
renewable and clean energy there may be
a build out of transmission
to achieve those policy goals but that
would not be based on a reliability need
and those costs would not be shared
based on the reliability formula that we
the second observation i would make is
that the pandemic did
bring about a reduction in electricity
demand initially
so about a year ago in the march time
frame we saw
electric demand in the region drop by
three to five percent
and we weren't sure how that trend would
be sustained because we had no data
historically to show how the country and
the region responds to
a pandemic like this but we actually saw
the demand on the grid come back pretty
significantly
and somewhat higher than expected when
it got warm
in the june and july time frame last
summer so we kind of rebounded
as a region in terms of the electricity
consumption
and you can imagine people left their
offices but you're still
seeing the electricity demand at the
office building at the same time
now all the employees are using
electricity at their home so
what happened in a sense is the
electricity demand just got spread
around
more and it's probably less efficient
that way
than to have people power down at home
and then power up at the office
in effect we're powering up you know
multiple locations
and i think that's just a reality for
the for the present hopefully that will
change
but we do see us coming to the end of
the build out of the reliability project
so
we shouldn't see transmission costs
which have risen we don't expect those
to grow
thank you follow up mr chair
yes thank you so
i guess what i'm looking at is is there
a
do you have projections that there will
be more
generation and power needed in in the
future
or will we soon be back to
somewhat uh pre-tran pre-transmission
days
and perhaps pre-pre pandemic days
uh or do you see a rise in the need for
for more generation good question
the the long-term forecast that we do is
updated every year
in the springtime and published on may
1st it's part of the forecast called the
capacity energy
load and transmission report the cell
report that looks out for 10 years
and we look at really two dimensions of
the forecast what's the peak
for the region and what's the total
energy consumption
across all 8760 hours in a year
and for both of those forecasts
we expect that the consumption will
essentially be flat for the region
and that's driven in large part by the
energy efficiency
across the states and the solar pv
they've really brought down the demand
for power
if you look beyond the 10-year horizon
we're anticipating that as you electrify
transportation as you have more and more
people driving plug-in vehicles
that need to charge on the grid and as
you shift away from
fossil fuels for heating and building
heating
to electrification which i think is the
direction the region is
is headed that will add more demand to
the grid so i think we've been in a
period
for the first 20 years of the iso where
we saw
steady growth and then it's leveling off
over the next 10 years
and then i expect it will grow again as
we electrify more and more
parts of our economy
thank you thank you representative
oxendine is recognized for a question
thank you very much mr chair for taking
my question and thank you
is it mr johnson or mr greenland
mr j eric johnson eric johnson thank you
very much as we we met
when we were all down at uh at iso thank
you
um if i could take us back to the
earlier discussion
um i i think we're we're left with
sort of two um two different ideas and
let me explain
uh that we've had presentations from des
as you know mike fitzgerald and chris
goblin and the chair of the air
divisions resource board
and their uh numbers vary from yours and
i think it's probably because you have
the broader
new england perspective whereas they
focus very
directly on what's happening in new
hampshire and
a court when we were in your offices
um down there in holyoke uh
we we were presented with graphs that
showed all the other states in new
england
were decreasing total load
and decreasing peak demand and as you
just
suggested that had a lot to do with very
aggressive policies
um in favor of renewable energy and
energy efficiency
and new hampshire was the outlier new
hampshire was still
increasing its load and increasing its
peak demand
um and it was pointed out to us there
and as i said by our des
experts that because of
the actions of others who are declining
in
load and peak and even if we were simply
to plateau
our usage we would still over time and
this is looking
forward not looking at historical
numbers
we would necessarily have to be taking a
larger
share of the total because
our share would be getting bigger and
the numbers
as i i don't have the um you point out
nine point five percent has been our
sort of average usage they were
suggesting that we would be over
ten percent um and i believe that was
in the next five to ten years and that
with every one tenth of one percent that
that goes up we are talking about
additional millions of dollars in monies
that would have to be
provided out of new hampshire to make up
the share
that others would not have so that i
think that's where our questions about
what is the
effect of renewable energy um
yeah i'll i'll just leave it there if it
having provided that background to
the controversy within our committee um
it might be helpful to you
to revisit that uh the point that you
were making
is it does it it's inconsistent to think
that our share would stay the same
while all of our partners are decreasing
their load and decreasing their peak
and we are not yeah
it's a it's a good observation i'm not
directly familiar with uh the data that
might have been presented by
uh des and if if they have information
i'd be happy to look at it
and compare it with what we've seen
we only are able to measure what's the
demand showing up on the transmission
system itself
so it's it's not as though we can see
load in layers where there's
in real time the demand for electricity
and then the impact of solar and then
the impact of energy efficiency it's not
metered that way and when you look into
our control room they have no visibility
on that so the i think the only way you
can get at this
is to do some some analysis after the
fact of how much you're spending
on energy efficiency and you probably
need to know what the other states are
spending on energy
efficiency and compare that to
your load so the the numbers would not
originate from the iso
other than what your total consumption
is i think that might be one of the
challenges
for us providing the answer to you but i
would be happy to work with you offline
to examine any data that you have uh to
the extent that's helpful
thank you so much and i i also think the
notion of you looking at the historical
data and then
projecting forward i think that also may
be a bit of our
differences here yes thank you so much
i'll follow up with you all right
uh representative samsit is recognized
for a question
uh yes thank you mr chairman thank you
mr johnson for being here
and making yourself available
um you probably know that one of the
the biggest discussion points here in
new hampshire
when it comes to electric bills has been
the dramatic increase in transmission
costs
and this is something that the
representative thomas mentioned
the i think over the last 10 years
the portion of our electric bill that
has been
increasing most dramatically has been
transmission costs
um the energy fuel supply
costs are pretty low and they've been
stable in fact they've been going down
over the years
and but the transmission costs continue
to rise
pretty dramatically from a small amount
maybe 10 years ago to
a significant amount right now so
represent thomas was asking just a
minute ago whether you expect
that that increase to to decrease the
increase of transmission costs i think
you said you do expect that to
to uh to be a
a slighter slope than it has been in the
past
is that correct yes so
if we think back to the time frame when
the iso started
operating the system we began the
planning process for
reliability needs around 2000
and there had been very little
transmission investment in new england
for decades really and much of the
investment had gone toward
uh generation and the nuclear fleet as
an example but not much investment in
transmission
and at that time the demand for
electricity was growing at
one to two percent annually so
we were having to plan and
build transmission infrastructure to
catch up with the growing
demand for power and any transmission
project we put in
into our plan is so that we don't
encounter
violations of our reliability standards
as an example as transmission lines get
with demand they heat up and they would
sag we need to make sure that
the wires that we have in the system can
handle that demand for electricity
we want to make sure that we meet the
voltage
and stability requirements that are set
by the federal government
and the north american electric
reliability corporation so
all of that transmission was was
designed to make sure
we can meet the growing demand for power
and we've been able to do that
effectively and we know that the demand
the growth and demand has has slowed we
expect it'll pick up
over time and
the transmission costs then increased as
well so you went from paying for
very little new investment to suddenly
having to absorb the cost of
10 billion dollars of investment that's
why you saw the transmission costs
become a larger share of your electric
bill
i'll make an analogy it's my own so as i
think about it if
if when you graduate from college and
you're fortunate enough that your aunt
gives you a hand-me-down vehicle
and you're able to drive that around for
a couple of years
your costs for operating that vehicle
are are minimal but at some point
you decide okay i need a vehicle that
will carry me forward for the next
couple of years reliably
then you purchase a vehicle and then you
have a car payment
so it's sort of like what happened in
the early 2000 time frame
the region had not been paying very much
for transmission
suddenly we needed to make this
investment and that became a larger
share
of the the cost for your electric bill
um we we have always made sure that if
we saw needs on the system
uh go away we could scale back or even
cancel transmission projects and we
certainly have done that so
it's not an automatic that a
transmission
project that starts in the study phase
will always be built
we're continuing to reassess what the
needs are and
modify our plan accordingly uh follow-up
mr chair
[Music]
well i'm glad you mentioned the issue of
the possible canceling of transmission
since i'm a physicist i've always had a
lot of focus on
how efficiently we use energy but if i
understand you correctly
um the the iso's role
does not involve how efficiently energy
is being used
that's an area that is out of your
responsibility
but i think about the analogy you
mentioned about your own home for
example
that would be if you're managing a
furnace but you're not managing
the installation of your home that's a
secondary issue
but as as we know if you insulate that
home you might need a smaller furnace
and you don't need as much transmission
for example so do you believe that maybe
iso at some point should set some kind
of energy standard
energy efficiency standards because that
directly impacts your
generation and the the transmission
lines
uh thank you representative could you
just clarify do you mean energy
efficiency standards for
consumers and buildings uh well i
i'm being a little late about it because
i don't know exactly
how you operate on this but i'm thinking
that
standards that say you know if the
energy that is being
provided is being inefficiently used
wasted in a big way should there not be
some standards to say you know we're
providing this energy
through our transmission lines uh and we
expect you to
use it efficiently but there are no
standards right now for that
is is there any kind of role for for iso
in that in that area to say in order for
us to get transmission costs down in
order for us to get generation costs
down
for everybody in the region uh one of
the tools might
be to have an energy efficient use of
energy standard that's an
interesting concept i would say the iso
does not have
any authority or jurisdiction to impose
any type of a standard like that
that would be the
responsibility of the federal government
which sets
uh standards or the the building codes
uh the appliance efficiency standards uh
you know states can set standards but
when we're serving demand on the grid
the iso is only seeing
the generation that's coming out of a
power plant
moving across the wires and getting
delivered to the distribution system we
don't
we don't see what's happening beyond
that so i couldn't tell you
and my operators couldn't tell you that
new england is
very efficient or not efficient at all
i know that the region spends about a
billion dollars
annually through ratepayer programs for
energy efficiency so
we certainly are more efficient than we
have been in the past
those are things like weatherization
as probably one of the biggest example
lighting anytime you
shift from one technology to another you
can reduce the total
lighting load in the region so those
would be examples
of improvements in efficiency but i
can't see the iso having a role
in setting those standards we just don't
have the expertise or the visibility on
that side of the system
thank you chair recognizes uh
thank you mr chairman uh god i got a ton
of questions but
let me try if i could narrow it down i
from what i understand
uh we lose a lot of energy
in transmission i have no idea what the
percentage is
by here it's a lot and
and i'm guessing it has a lot to do
with just the distance that electricity
has to
travel i think of myself uh if
i'm using an extension cord
um the further i have to run
power to to get to what i want to do
the larger the uh gauge of wire i need
to run etc otherwise the water
the wire heats up and you're just losing
energy all over the place
but so i guess my question is
um how much power are we losing are
there ways to
mitigate that i i know i've i've heard
about
microgrids and how would that fit into
maybe reducing the lengths of
transmission
you could just comment on that generally
it's kind of a lot to talk about or
think about
all at once uh thank you representative
pimentel
uh there are losses on the system
so if you are producing electricity at a
power plant
in maine for example and that
electricity
is going to be delivered to a part of
the system in
connecticut there will be losses over
that transmission system
those losses are not large that's a
relative
assessment i think they're typically in
the plus or minus two to three percent
of the total system and
when we plan the system when you have
larger
conductors you reduce the amount of
losses because there's less resistance
for the
current moving through that line and
that's something that we take stock of
uh i i wouldn't say that there's a lot
of
energy being wasted in losses in the
region
uh the the only way to eliminate losses
entirely i suppose
would be to produce electricity on site
where it's consumed
and a microgrid is an example of that
but i'm not sure that that's an economic
model for a population of 14 million
people
so that's my initial thought on the on
and i think you had other questions i'm
i'm happy to stay on or
representative pementel
don't forget to unmute
encouraging to know i i had heard that
the transmission losses
were you know in the you know tens or 20
but a couple percent that's not bad so
thank you for that information i
uh representative mcgee is recognized
thank you mr chair i just put my hand up
i wasn't expecting to be next
my question is a little more about
scale of power on we have to consider
and balance a number of different things
and we know that the system is complex
i know that there's been a
decommissioning plan which i really
don't hear much about
or know much about but
i know that when we closed for example
yankee
just over the border in vermont there
was a significant
economic impact in the region and
there's also sort of a loss
of some clean energy base load so i'm
trying to figure out how the iso
what you have to say about the iso's
management
of um you know our
limited clean base load resources that
are on the grid
and and how that affects the again
reliability going forward because i i
know with some of those retirements
there were reports that came out of the
iso that said
that you that the that the
management of the reliability was
becoming less stable and i i i wonder if
you could speak to that because i think
it's something we don't talk about very
often but i'd like to understand it
better
okay very good thank you representative
uh if you think about
nuclear as a technology at one point i
think new england had nine
reactors so we had a significant amount
of
power coming from nuclear uh the vermont
yankee plant was one of the smaller
reactors i think it's about it was about
600 megawatts
and they had a similar the company owned
a similar plant
in pilgrim that has also retired and
so we have seen a loss of some of the
diversity
of supply but the iso doesn't have
a reliability standard for
fuel mix or technology types so
we don't have the ability to retain
a power plant like the vermont yankee
we could look at delaying the retirement
of the project of the plant
until we could reinforce the
transmission system
and we've done that with some large
power stations we did that as i
mentioned with the mystic
station with the i think brayton point
and pilgrim
may have had some upgrades that were
needed but we
we don't have the ability to keep a
plant so if a company says we're going
to shut this plant down we can try to
uh prolong that for a very short period
of time
and they can say no and they can shut
down the plan
so that does present some challenges
been in discussions with the states
about you know what's the future
of uh the the resource mix then we
expect
over time it will be some nuclear will
remain on the system you obviously you
folks have one of the
one of the plants in new hampshire
millstone is the other one
we'll have natural gas fire generation
and then we'll have a growing amount
of renewable energy it will probably be
more of a challenge
for the states in terms of their clean
energy goals
as well and again that's not something
that
falls under the isos jurisdiction it's
really the states that have decided they
want
a certain portion of their resource mix
to come from
clean or renewable sources of energy
but anytime a plant wants to connect to
the grid we study it anytime they want
to
retire from the grid we study that too
but there are limits to our
the tools that we have in our toolbox if
a large power station wants to go away
chair recognizes representative oxen for
a question
i think my question was answered thank
you very much
representative thank you mr chair i got
two
questions actually one is the increase
in transmission
uh the 10 billion you mentioned over the
last uh 10 years
is that just dead weight costs or is
there offsetting
can't commit and benefit such as
reduction in
congestion charges and costs of lost
power that is avoided
uh representative plett that's a great
question
we have seen significant uh reductions
in other costs as a result of the
upgrades we've done for reliability
and when i say we it's really the the
transmission companies have
built those projects there was uh
significant congestion
in the system the ability to move the
the cheapest price
power around the network and as we've
reinforced the transmission system we've
seen
more more ability for the lowest price
resources to move around the grid so
that's clearly a benefit
we also had hundreds of millions of
dollars in
reliability agreements for individual
power plants
and as we develop the transmission
system
uh particularly in uh in southwest
connecticut as an example we saw those
uh reliability agreements uh expire
so there certainly have been benefits
that have gone along with that
i do have some data on that and i would
be happy to submit that to the committee
as a
as a follow-up thank you the other one
uh
isn't it true because we have a market
where we didn't used to have a market
uh then i i still really came about
about the time the formation of the
market
that you have less that you have to
build more transmission under a market
condition than you would under the old
system of utilities built in generation
because they could build it where they
i don't have an answer to that i i would
be speculating so
you're asking me to compare one model to
the other
and uh i don't feel like i have it
i will avert that that's the case that
uh but
rather than building a replacement stay
for uh
uh a great point uh you had to
try you had to reinforce transmission
same thing with uh mystic
you have to build transmission rather
than build another plant there
because you don't know another plant
will be built
okay if in in that example
transmission is the tool that we have
to ensure a reliable system if a
resource retires
it is true that in a vertically
integrated system
the planners might decide that they want
to invest in
a new power plant at that site instead
of building transmission
but we don't have the ability to plan
generation the way we do
the transmission system thank you
representative pled i remind you we're
here to ask questions not debate
uh representative bernard is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
johnson um
i was delighted to hear your your
losses from wheeling is around two
percent going from maine to connecticut
on high
transmission lines like the like the
transmission system of iso
has do are you aware
does that same loss uh
uh amount apply to when we step down to
the distribution
side of the list uh
so uh we're we're now looking at power
losses
in in in the distribution grid
is it still at that low amount or
because
because of the smaller wires uh
we we're seeing increased distribution
losses and and the reason i asked this
question is because
you mentioned and this committee has has
discussed the concept
of you know uh transportation
moving to electrified vehicles and now
we're
now we're uh positioning ourselves to
say
oh well you know that that is going to
be a net
cost saving and that benefit to the to
the economy
uh i am not sure that if we have
some significant distribution
losses that we gain that that benefit
um so i but i don't know if that's
within your wheelhouse to answer that
question either
i'm i'm not an engineer and
i wouldn't want to speculate i think the
best uh
source of information would be uh one of
the distribution companies
uh psnh for example they can tell you
what the losses would be
between the point we drop power off at
the
distribution system and where they
deliver it to the end use customer
we just don't have visibility on that
system
thank you representative brezhnev is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
johnson for taking my question
you mentioned that transportation is
expected to become the largest share of
electric demand
increase over the next decade if
massachusetts which is a much larger
state with 77
000 miles of road compared to new
hampshire which only has 16 000 miles of
road
would you project that as everyone moves
to electrified transportation
that electric demand in massachusetts
would accelerate much faster than in new
hampshire
and therefore their percentage of the
load would would go up faster than
the hampshire's percentage of the loan
it it you're asking me to to speculate
on something
um we don't know how quickly
the states are going to deploy
electric vehicles over time we're
starting to forecast that
on an annual basis we're in the second
year of developing that forecast but the
numbers
um are based on limited data
i mean if you if you ask any people in a
group how many
drive an electric vehicle you get a
couple hands going up
uh the question is how many people will
be driving electric vehicle in 5 years
10 years 15 years
[Music]
we hope to have better information about
that over time
our information is somewhat limited
i guess so my question isn't so much how
quickly this would happen it's more of
the relationship between assuming that
new hampshire and massachusetts
adopt electrify their transportation at
around the same rate would would
massachusetts
because they're a much larger state
their demand for electricity
would go up much faster than new
hampshire do you see
do you project that sort of relationship
we don't make a projection of that
relationship but
if if i consider your hypothetical i
think the answer is yes
um that assumes that the demand
for satisfying the demand for electric
vehicles is coming from the grid itself
we also don't know if customers are
using on-site
uh solar or if they're using a battery
to
bank energy during the day from the grid
um and discharge it in the morning when
they go to work so there are other
variables in that equation but it is
possible if they do a
rapid deployment of electric vehicles
they would see
more demand on the grid than new
hampshire assuming that you don't
thank you mr johnson okay the chair
recognizes representative christian for
a question
thank you mr chair um it's actually i
guess two
points or items i guess related to that
um
i just wanted to mention i saw in the
new york times they had a really
interesting infographic about the pace
of
um electrified vehicle adoption and
how long it'll take existing vehicles to
to get off the road that
i thought people might be interested in
i also wanted to
question um mileage of road
as the best proxy for miles driven
or transportation energy use i think
um it's probably more dependent on
number of cars
and miles driven than just the miles of
road that are available
and i don't know if those numbers are
comparable but i just
suggest um mr brushney that you might
want to look at that
um as well or instead
is there a question there no
okay thank you uh
representative thomas you still have
yes i do thank you
uh mr johnson um let's get back to
transmission for a second uh first of
all
i just want to make a comment uh
interestingly enough
or not too surprisingly uh on your iso
new england
app its demand and real-time wholesale
energy prices
have been zero throughout new england
for the last half an hour
at at least interesting statistic there
my my question goes back to transmission
to be cl to clarify
the transmission costs that show up on
our electric bills provided by our
electric utility company those costs
are totally dictated
by iceland new england in terms of what
their share is to charge the customers
or does the electric utility
have any um additional input into what
uh what the cost of the transmission is
yeah the iso does not dictate that uh
the the rate that's charged the regional
network service rate that's charged
is developed by the transmission owners
the transmission companies across new
england
they bring that to ferc ferc approves it
and then those costs are
essentially passed through to
end-use customers and there's a role for
the states
in authorizing those charges on the
end use customers bill
at that point i don't think the states
have any specific control over that it's
just
authorizing it to go on the electric
bill but the iso does not dictate
uh the cost we simply show what the
uh the regional network load is for each
of the
the transmission companies and that's as
i mentioned that gets rolled up into
into the states so this is more of a
decision that's between the transmission
companies
and the proceeding at ferc than the iso
we certainly have a role in identifying
the transmission that's
needed and we do that through our
planning process
we seek to develop transmission that's
cost effective but when it comes to the
the billing and determining the cost
allocation that's
not specifically an iso role
uh follow-up mr chair hello
okay i'm i'm trying to get to the bottom
of a lot of people when they talk about
the fact that our transmission costs are
up
and uh you're as you can imagine there
are a lot of fingers pointing
both ways when they they talk about this
so
is it my based on what you said so
when the local electric company goes for
it to get its
rate approved uh they have it done
through our
uh puc here in the state which but you
mentioned ferc
now i guess uh
are you telling me that it's it's all
rolled up in the cost of doing business
but ferc has to approve
certain costs that the electric utility
can bring before the puc
as part of their rate adjustment um
and plus i'm sure they would be uh added
in there they're
they're you know regulated um you know
profit margin as well
i'm just trying to get a handle on just
who
decides and what input
there is on the actual cost of
transmission is
who determines that who i mean
what are all the factories i mean we're
being told one side is responsible
because
they're perhaps not managing efficiently
or the other side is saying that
no it's not us it's what we're being
told to charge
by other entities i'm trying to get my
finger on
how transmission costs are actually
established
okay so if we it's a good question if
you back up a little bit
and you take uh the bulk transmission
system that's
in service or planned or under
construction
there's a cost for that that's
essentially financed over time
somewhat like a mortgage you don't buy a
house for cash
you pay for it over time so the
transmission system
is built and financed over time
the cost for recovering
that investment is done through a rate
that the transmission companies bring to
ferc because we're talking about
transmission that's engaged in
uh interstate commerce effectively and
and i'm not a lawyer so i'm speaking
generally
so ferc approves uh that rate
and then the the cost of that
transmission
are brought to the public utility
commissions
essentially and they say we have the uh
ferc approval for this component of the
transmission
of the customer's bill and then that
gets added into the
retail customers bill so the states are
not
directly approving the transmission cost
it's a it's a pass through based on
something that was approved at ferc
and the the folks that the public
utility commission
uh would be the best ones to explain how
that comes through in
a rate case uh because they see that
directly
the iso does not see the the retail
billing side of it because our customers
are not end-use customers our customers
so we we might have to talk offline and
look at some numbers to unpack those
questions a little bit more
but there are essentially ferc approvals
for some components of the bill
and state puc approvals for other
components of the bill
okay thank you it clarifies it somewhat
for me thank
okay you you representative partial is
recognized for a question
thank you chairman for taking my
question for uh inviting our guests
today it's very informative
um i've been looking a little bit trying
to wrap my mind around the idea of this
rejected energy
seems to play a percentage in all of our
neighboring states and in new hampshire
as well
um and a subject that came up earlier in
our discussions
earlier this session was the idea of
battery backup
is that a really an uh
technology that we can really apply
right now does that be applied anywhere
aside from there's that one
plant in massachusetts that pumps water
up and down
is there any other real viable use of
that type of
that technology at this point that
you're aware of
uh thank you representative partial
we have batteries that have been
existence for a number of years the pump
storage that you mentioned
but we also have a very sizable amount
of battery storage technology that's
been proposed
and i know this is a an issue that
representative oxenham brings up and i i
had the numbers i was ready
ready for her for ready for her question
uh so write this down representative 3
635 megawatts of battery storage
battery storage a couple years ago was
in the kind of miscellaneous category
when you look in the queue and i
remember when i would
re report to her that the number was up
to 50 megawatts
and uh she was very excited so now we're
at over 3000 so
those projects are being put forward by
developers who see an opportunity
to charge those batteries at one point
in the day and discharge those batteries
at another point in the day they might
be doing that based on what's happening
with price
we would call that arbitrage within the
market
they may be doing that because they're
paired with a renewable resource
so maybe you have more energy than the
grid needs
coming from renewable so you you charge
the battery with
wind power or solar power
um but we are we are seeing significant
quantities of battery storage start to
show up
like you want to follow up
thank you again um and if we can
increase our
battery storage capacity then we would
be decreasing the amount of rejected
energy that we have
and we would be providing both more
stability
and uh smaller carbon footprint at the
if you're using a battery a battery
itself is
not um
emitting electricity or
it's not emitting any uh environmental
uh characteristics it depends on what
it's being charged with so if it's just
being charged from the grid
then when it's discharged the output of
that battery is really
whatever was operating on the grid at
the time it's a mix
if if it's not connected to the grid but
it's connected on the customer side of
the meter
then it would be charging with the solar
array that might be on the rooftop
or if it's a wind project it would be
charged with the
the wind and then the battery would be
discharging
renewable energy because that was its
source so i think you always have to
look at how is the battery configured
on the system is it tied directly to a
customer
or is it tied directly to the grid and
may ask one more follow-up question i do
apologize
one more go ahead yes um
but if we are we maybe i do not
understand the concept of reject
of rejected electric uh rejected
production
if we have an excess at certain points
that we're not able to accommodate on
our grid
um but if we're able to capture that
doesn't that uh um
provide more at least more stability i
understand the batteries are
not they're not neutral they're not
green they're not carbon
i understand that part of the concept
but i'm thinking about the amount of
electricity they're producing
that is rejected and i guess i don't
understand that concept maybe you could
um the the concept of rejected
could you just clarify what you mean
it's not a term that we
we refer to with a grid okay i was
looking at a document john mann in
particular maybe he can
step in if he understands this my
understand is there's overproduction at
certain times of the
cycle and that overproduction uh
cause would be this is invest
goes nowhere basically
so actually that doesn't happen we don't
have
over production on the system uh if we
did we would have a problem in our
control center because they need to make
sure that the supply and demand
are in balance constantly if there's an
over production of power the
what happens is we start exporting power
to our neighbors that they're not
expecting and they're going to call us
and say new england what's going on why
are you sending us more power than you
have scheduled so we never
run more generation than we need
it's possible you may this may be
related to
let's say a wind farm for example we
don't have the ability to
ramp them up and down the way we would
have other resources but
there may be times when there's more
wind production capability than the grid
demands
and we would have to curtail those
resources
so that might be what they rejected the
concept of rejected energy is
but okay pretty absolutely thank you for
your answer i appreciate your time
okay thank you uh let's see
representative mann has recognized my
question
yeah yeah thank you mr chairman i just
my my thought about the rejected energy
it was that it was uh
energy that could not be turned into
useful purposes for example uh
uh heat energy in a in a in a locomotive
or
friction things like that i'm i'm pretty
sure
that was the um the point of the
graph i've always assumed that let's put
it that way
these are um i can't remember the name
of the
federal um okay that
um this is those grass but they're uh
kind of kind of interesting sorry
so live or more maybe mr mr chairman
just a brief
uh follow-up if if i may on that
question
sure go ahead um if you think about the
generation technologies we have a couple
of
examples of gas turbines one is the
the simple cycle turbine where you put
fuel
into the the system
much like a jet engine but we've also
developed a significant amount of
combined cycle
resources and so rather than simply
ejecting the waste
in the form of heat they capture
that heat and return it to the system
and the efficiency of that power plant
goes up significantly
so what we've seen in new england is
generation technologies have
moved toward more efficient use of that
heat that's on the grid system and then
i know within
many municipal systems they use heat
waste
for um steam loops and
uh other other purposes that are
thank you representative mann for
clarifying what the concept
was
representative samsuche is recognized
for a question
yes thank you mr chairman thank you mr
johnson
uh a little while back you were talking
about like future projections
uh that isil is seeing and
i want to get back to that in the
context of your responsibilities for
transmission
um number one right now i see
currently very imminently one of the
issues i'm sure you're you're working on
right now is
internet security and resiliency of the
grid because that's becoming more and
more important everywhere and that's
immediately needed now but in the medium
term
like was mentioned before about
transportation
it's not just about electric vehicles
but
basically a lot of vehicles in the
hybrid so they're using some electricity
as well as some gas but we're moving
more and more to
all electric vehicles so that
potentially will be a bigger demand in
the future
and then further into the future you're
going to be seeing
huge amounts possibly of generation of
offshore winds into the grid so
are those areas all being considered at
i
i think i think the short answer is yes
in terms of the grid security
and cyber security that's something we
take very seriously
we work very closely with the north
american electric reliability
corporation
nerc and every two years we run a major
exercise called grid x
and it's a simulation of physical and
cyber attacks
on the power grid in north america
and it's a way for us in a controlled
environment separate from the actual
grid to test our processes
and procedures and our ability to
operate the system when it's
under attack so there's
continuous learning from those types of
exercises
for those who have been down to visit
the iso you know that you have to
get security clearance in advance to
come through the gate
there's a physical perimeter security
with a guard
we essentially have that same perimeter
around
the network that's operating the system
so iso new england may have a corporate
website
the control center that's actually
operating the grid so
i just want to assure you that the the
grid itself is not hosted on the
internet it's a completely
separate uh network with significant
cyber security controls around it
and we know that the cyber threats are
continuing to evolve so we need to
continually talk to our colleagues we
need we talk with the fbi
homeland security to make sure we
understand what are the emerging
threats and how can we take actions to
stop those attacks from penetrating our
system
and mitigating the consequences so we
take that very seriously
the other question was about offshore
wind
and offshore wind used to be kind of a
smaller slice
of what's in the isoq it's now the
dominant resource
so we have over 15 000 megawatts of wind
that's proposed in new england much of
it's in
southern new england the massachusetts
area there's uh offshore leases that
have been designated for
uh development of offshore wind and so
we work with
all of the developers to interconnect
those projects on shore
and then we're also working with the new
england states who are looking much
longer term at the 2050 time frame to
understand what kind of transmission
would you need to interconnect uh large
quantities of offshore wind even more
than what's being studied
today and we're evaluating that
currently with the new england states
and be happy to keep the committee
apprised of
that study effort those are the two
concepts i
recall from the question if there were
others thank you very much mr johnson
okay thank you representative bernardi
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
johnson uh
delighted to hear about uh you know your
efforts in cyber security but uh
interested in understanding what work
uh iso is doing to
yeah so you're talking about
electromagnetic pulse
and this is something that we've worked
very closely with ferc our federal
regulator
and there are working groups that are
continually evaluating those risks
that the equipment in the field
is not owned by the iso so we don't own
any transmission or
generation so the assets that could be
impacted by an emp or
some type of geometric geomagnetic
disturbance
they're not our assets so we can't
harden them directly
so we have to work with the owners of
those assets and the industry
to find ways to do that
in short of dropping a faraday cage over
the entirety of new england there will
be risks
and there are things that have been done
to to harden that network
we watch the the solar forecast not just
for
solar panels but the what's the activity
on the sun
and track when there are solar storms so
we can anticipate
how that might impact the bulk
transmission system
and this gets into some really
interesting uh
physics around the the location of the
pole on the earth and the further north
you go
you know the the greater the risk is for
some of the uh geomagnetic
activity and i know that the folks in
maine have looked at this
very closely so the short answer is we
work with
our regulators to assess this we work
with the industry
but it's a challenge for us to actually
harden the assets
uh is there any uh
discussions with the suppliers about
having uh the the big transformers that
that would be potentially destroyed by
an emp
and knock out our whole electric system
having them have standby is
it's a good question i understand that
there are
stockpiles of transformers that the
utilities companies have
access to of course the challenge might
be
if the impacts are widespread how do you
decide who is
it's really a question for the utility
companies that own that equipment they
i'm sure have plans i just would be
speculating if i said how they would
deal with that in
new hampshire or any other new england
states
thank you thank you uh representative
oxendine is recognized for a question
thank you mr chair and i'd very much
like to
thank mr johnson for thinking of me and
preparing that
information on on battery storage um and
my second point is that as we look
forward and as
iso is planning forward over the next 10
and 30 years
you know we we have to leave room for
innovation battery storage
the batteries themselves are changing
the the confirmation is changing
and um i i think that
as we go forward we always have to leave
room for the
for the excitement of that r d that's
coming online
new resources that are coming online and
and with each step
we we have taken really qualitatively
um order magnitude changes in terms
of efficiency and and and that
that is really the nub that we have been
able you know when we moved from wood
to fossil fuels there was a tremendous
efficiency jump
and moving away from fossil fuels now to
new forms and new technologies
that new efficiency is going to allow us
all these uses of beneficial
electrification
and evs that so often we get bogged down
and worrying oh
where are we going to find that it's
they're they're coming along in
you know it won't always be perfect it
won't always be in sync
they're going to be discontinuities but
um
i i for one am very optimistic about
this and
and and just wanted to really reach out
and thank you for your your presentation
today was
representatives mcgee is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chairman and i echo thank
you so much
mr johnson for coming and speaking with
us today this has been great
um i attended the iso new england
10-year strategy session in 2019
and it struck me at that meeting um
that we have uh iso is dedicated to a
specific
aspect of our reliability for the grid
which makes perfect sense
um and other entities are um
responsible for different aspects as you
mentioned your interactions with ferc
and with
suppliers and transmission uh
transmission the people who who
basically support the transmission
uh fit the physicality of the
transmission
uh portion of the grid so i i wonder if
you could say something about
whether the siloed
nature of uh of the work that we do with
the grid
um actually presents part of the risk
that we face because i think it's it's
one of those things where
we don't do that we don't do that so i
just i just wonder
how much of a risk are we assuming by
the fact that
um the responsibility for maintaining
that's a good observation um when you
talk about security are you
referring to cyber security
or simply the the general security of
having
enough resources to meet the demand for
power i just want to make sure i
understand the question
uh the former yeah um
so there is an effort in the region
where the iso coordinates with the new
england states
on cyber security and
there is uh discussion among the new
england conference of public utilities
commissioners or neck puck
chair uh diane martin and her colleagues
at the puc
are part of that um in the past
we've worked directly with um
commissioner bob scott who was the
cyber security lead and there are other
people who are part of that regional
discussion from other
states so there is communication between
the iso
and the state regulators so they
understand
us the risks that we see and they
provide
insights that they have from the work
that they're doing within their states
we coordinate with the national guard
the fbi
homeland security so it may appear
siloed but there's
a pretty extensive coordination between
the isos and
our peers in the industry we talked to
all the other isos about this
asking what kind of risks that they see
for the region could they potentially
spill over to new england the fbi
provides alerts to us if we detect
problems we share that with the fbi and
they have a network to share that
information as well so it's probably not
as siloed as you might
uh think but we have to be cautious
about
how we share that information externally
so we're not
unwittingly providing a blueprint to
somebody who might want to
do something to attack the grid that
makes sense yeah thank you
i appreciate that good question thank
you
okay thank you i have another question
i know you've talked about this already
the anticipated
bill build out um or
in relation to representative brushy's
question about the
build out of electric vehicles
and the increase on the load but can you
also talk for a moment about the build
out of
solar projects and other such projects
in massachusetts
and how they'll affect transmission
costs
that won't be included or reflected in
if we think about the the solar that's
been built recently here
i don't know if you can you're allowed
to do this on zoom but i'll hold up a
chart
i feel like ross perot right so
here's a chart if i get this right this
shows the growth in solar
in new england the small number in this
chart
is uh back in the beginning there was 40
megawatts of solar
and in the region we now have a forecast
of almost
8 000 megawatts of solar and then we can
break that down
by state and i'll provide this to the
committee so you have the data
but massachusetts has a hundred thousand
installations of solar as of december
new hampshire has 10 000 so that gives
you a sense of the relative scale
they've already installed a lot of solar
we have numbers for the other states as
well connecticut
massachusetts tend to be the leaders on
the development of solar pv
so if you think about uh
what's happening they would effectively
reduce potentially reduce
the demand on the electric grid by
installing that solar because the
customers
are using power from the panels rather
than from the grid
so that could reduce their share of that
regional
network load as those solar panels
come online now the transmission costs
keep in mind are allocated on a monthly
basis so the amount of solar production
you get
in the darker days of the winter might
be different than in the spring
summer and fall so you probably would
have to look at snapshots
throughout the year to get a better
sense of that but to the extent
you are installing solar panels on the
customer side of the meter
it would be reducing the the demand on
the grid and that does have the
potential to reduce
their share of the transmission costs
so to follow up on that question in the
winter when
solar panels are not producing very much
electricity would massachusetts share of
transmission load go up as opposed to
in the summer time when there is a lot
of solar available
i would say that's possible but i'd have
to go back and look at some of the
numbers on that before i make a
projection
about that i'd have be happy to give
that some further thought
okay so just uh one more follow-up
if the upgrades that are needed
to connect all this solar to the grid
uh run in the hundreds of millions of
dollars
does that affect transmission costs at
all or is that strictly a
well there would not be any uh cost to
interconnect
a solar behind the meter that would be
allocated to the region
those would be a distribution charge
under the jurisdiction of each
individual state
and if you had a large solar project
let's say
200 megawatts that wanted to connect to
the system
if they needed to upgrade the network to
accommodate
the interconnection the developer pays
those costs
so i don't see any place
where the cost of interconnecting solar
would be allocated
okay thank you so do we have any uh
further questions
seeing none mr johnson i want to thank
you heartily on behalf of the full
committee for
taking time to be with us today and
answering all our questions and
helping us understand just how uh costs
on the transmission
grid affect the uh the cost on our
electoral bill we really appreciate
you being here thank you mr chairman i
always enjoy the conversation and look
forward to meeting with you again
excellent thank you very much okay so
it isn't 7 30 and
we have no further formal business to
conduct i would ask
does anybody have anything that they
would like to discuss
informally
if not then oh representative oxford
go ahead can you hear me
yes excellent i just wondered if we
might want to
put forward a date for another meeting
just in case
one of these opportunities should arise
for another presentation
or something on a retained bill in terms
of an expert
because we you know we have to get the
room allocated and all that
well based on um the allocation of
rooms and zoom licenses stne is assigned
to mondays so we could probably get this
room
on monday for any one of
the next several weeks we can
occasionally get it on friday depending
on
how other committees schedules are
running
so i will look into that and see what
days are available
and it'll be at this point
problematic for me to try to schedule a
a presentation already in hand
that would be kind of a waste of
resources so it's also hard to set
to get someone to make an appointment
with you when you can't offer them a
date
is it understood but um
that's part of the coordination that we
have to do to
make these presentations happen so we'll
thank you so much
and try to get something going if you
have any suggestions representative
octaneum of presentations you'd like to
hear if you're be sure to share those
with me
in the email and i will see if i can
make those
make those happen representative callie
pitts
you're still muted
we have and i want to apologize for
leaving the meeting
but do we have anything coming over from
the senate yet
nothing has been assigned are you aware
of anything no nothing has been assigned
to us yet
not yet so that would be the end of
april we're looking at the end of april
mid-april
no i anticipate that we will be assigned
some bills before then
um crossover is officially now
april 9th i believe
april 9th last session so there will be
most of the bills will come over after
april 9th but i i've been told that some
of them will get here before that but i
don't have any
exact dates so i can't i can't make any
concrete plans at this point i was just
wondering if anything had dribbled over
yet
okay thank you i'm not sure dribbling is
how they'll get here but
[Laughter]
although it is march madness time the
ncaa basketball tournament is ongoing
right and we are in and but my concern
is school vacation week is coming up and
that's the last week in april
and i wondered how busy we were going to
be that last week in april so
just uh okay
some of us still have little ones around
i believe that's last week in march not
april
is that correct school week vacation
yeah nope
april yeah definitely april
i don't have any kids in school so i'm
not sure but i think
i have grandkids in new york and they
haven't last week in march
but we're in april new york we're in
facebook we're the last week in april
new york gets passover and easter off so
they take that opening
yep have a good weekend everybody hope
it gets warmer
okay i guess we're done uh do everybody
have a great weekend and thanks for
being here today
and i'll be in touch take care thank you
chairman